if you spend any time apologizing to
employees [__] you that's so bold bit G
but I want to make a point I'm going to
explain what I mean and I and I went for
bold attention is the number one asset
as the best leaders in the world take
the pressure and stops with them and
they convert it underneath them the
worst leaders in the world feel pressure
and pass that [__] down and a lot of you
do that real talk and you're like oh I'm
sorry I was stressed I lost you go in a
if you spend any time apologizing to
employees [__] you that's so bold bit G
I want to make a point listen if you're
excusing Behavior where you're yelling
and screaming at people with an apology
you are not as good as you think you are
I don't care how much money you're
making and I highly challenge this group
of winners to get stronger and be an
actual leader and when you have pressure
coming to you AKA losing losing an
employee losing an account losing a
pitch and I challenge you to have it
stop with you and come convert it to
self-reflection and compassion and
empathy do you thank your team massively
for the efforts of trying to win a pitch
when you lose it or only when you win it
fear is a short-term
motivator I want to open up to questions
from the audience that was great that
was fantastic thank
you thank you are there questions from
the audience we got we got microphones
there's one right over there oh we get
this SP the back and then we'll get how
are you my friend give me your name
O'Brien O'Brien yeah like last name
except it's my first name epic We call
we call him OB I like Brian it's a real
pleasure brother how are you hey good
good thank you for coming um I I'm
curious the answer to this but I think
it' also be helpful for a lot of people
in the room you know back to your
LinkedIn comment about how your
advertising business is running all of
your sales through Linkedin I think
conversations I've had with people
there's a struggle to connect what we do
from a relationship building standpoint
in the real world with the marketing
efforts that go on on LinkedIn and I
would just be curious how you think
about converting real world
relationships from an online platform in
the marketing I love it I think you
should use LinkedIn as a gateway drug to
play golf with people to have wine
dinner with people to I think to your
point O'Brien I don't think people
realize all I want LinkedIn for is the
attention
but what you put in the creative will be
the variable of your success so when
they make a post from the master you
know account if you then put hey first
eight people that email me I've got a
steak dinner for you to talk about this
and depth or any other business things
here's the RSVP way you've now taken
digital and use it as a gateway drug to
do
physical so I'm all I want to do is
create the Arbitrage of getting
attention to convert into however you
convert I don't get $20 million fee
Scopes just from the LinkedIn I get the
attention of saying something smart and
then they hit me up and I'm not talking
about using LinkedIn the way you might
have tried in the past which is spamming
people and sending them messages I'm
talking about putting out meaningful
content in the feed because LinkedIn is
now a Content platform that happens to
have recruiting on it and so that's how
Brian right you use the content to spark
the conversation to then do the golf to
do the steak dinner to do the whatever
you want to do like always willing to do
a 15-minute Zoom for free to talk about
this a little deeper if this can help
you even if it doesn't I go right at it
I have unlimited things where I'm like
I'm not here to be transactional but I'm
not Mother Teresa I'll spend 15 minutes
with you and go deeper into what I just
talked about there I understand that you
may not hire me because of that cuz
you're already in another partnership
but I'm going to leave a very strong
deposit as a human being in our 15
minutes on Zoom
or a 30-minute coffee at Starbucks that
hopefully in 3 years or from Word of
Mouth leads to something so I think
there's a way to be transparent but also
be incredibly intellectually generous
that's great question over there is it
on hi hi Gary I'm such a big fan of
yours birthday today so if we get a
picture later I would love that I'm in
what what's your name I'm Jessica bass
this is my first um producer event
here
uh your content around attention
grabbing has really inspired me to step
outside of my comfort zone and post
myself more on LinkedIn so thank you for
that but my question is really around
Jen ear you talk a lot about them being
lazy and just kind of poke myths and and
some of those um you know stereotypes of
Jen ear but and and real quick because I
just want to make sure to Lance I
actually don't think there any like I
know unlimited lazy Boomers and gen
xers
unlimited I think they have way more
options than we have
grasped go ahead for sure for sure and
that's my question because that's our
future right the people doing the work
back at the office are Jers we want to
keep them keep them happy we're also
trying to create a return to work
culture that inspires them and teaches
them about our culture and also
opportunities within our organization
yep how do we balance the two and keep
them happy um and also keep them at our
firm purple right to the top right to
your point like the entitlement is
absurd I had a leader talking with
somebody in our office we're bringing
plenty of people back too everyone's
going through the same thing so the kid
says Hey brother I'd love to come to the
office but I got a problem I live 40
minutes away and I have to bring all my
stuff stuff this is real by the way the
kid goes yeah I have to bring my laptop
and then there's a pause this is no
[__] stick with me he goes and the
charger
so I'm with you I'm aware of where we're
at I believe it's a game of numbers to
answer how I'm solving it for my
organization and all my startup and all
the boards I'm on and all the companies
I'm involved in I'm just telling them
find you know you got to kiss a bunch of
frogs to find a prince like I don't know
like if you sense entitlement and
laziness in the interview or the
conversation or if they ask ridiculous
questions don't hire them like to me I
love Merit like Merit you know but I
think the mistake we're making is we're
labeling them that's like labeling all
women it's crazy what we're doing with
this generation we all know that
labeling in groups is terrible and by
the way gen Z is contributing heavily
they've got all sorts of feelings of
everybody older like the greatest way to
be happy is number three in the world
the greatest way by the way if you're
not 100% happy as you sit here today
I've got the medicine for you and it's
free it's called number three the second
you realize that you are fully in
control of of your life is the second
you get happier when you think the
president has an impact on your success
that means you're a
loser all right we got one right there
and then Paige and then go to Ryan hi uh
Michelle Michelle um just because you
just hit on accountability can you talk
a little bit about how what you view and
how you define
accountability versus responsibility
because I think accountability is a
little bit of a scary word for people
and I think maybe for some of those in
this room as I'm a newbie so I'll go out
and a Li and say that but I've I've
heard you talk about accountability and
I like your honesty behind it and the
challenge behind it can you just well
with the way you asked the question my
belief is that if we all agree that
something is my responsibility and it
does not go well then I need to be 100%
accountable
like the amount of leaders and CEO and
leaders I talk to that will tell me the
reason this year went bad was well their
head of sales was just [__] the bed or
my CFO like they just keep talking and
literally I wait I eat it I Rope A Dope
little Muhammad Ali George Foreman and
then I go in for my move I'm like you
hired
them you allowed to fire them I have
good news
100% of the problems in your business
are your
fault
like it's true and and in this framework
the energy in this kind of framework of
a business the en if you spend one
minute crying about what they're doing
in corporate that's a minute you're not
spending on the [__] that you do
control I just will never understand it
I sit on some nonprofit s on excuse me
some I sit on the board of Bojangles
right franchise or franchisee and all
these people they're like you know some
franchisee came up to me because they
know I'm on the board and they just
start [__] on the brand and they're
like he's like G you have to understand
entrepreneur to entrepreneur this is a
real problem I looked him dead in the
face and said bro you're not an
entrepreneur if you sit in a framework
where you rely on a corporate entity to
be a partner you're not a full bred
entrepreneur and you must face that that
is the truth if he was a I said to him
right to his face I said if you're not
entrepreneur you would start instead of
having a franchisee of Bojangles you
would start Schmo
shangle and this goes back to
self-awareness period so what do I think
about accountability I think it stuns me
with all the [__] that's going on in my
life how happy I am and when I
deconstructed that over 25 years number
three is the game it gets really good
it's why everyone's so unhappy right now
they actually believe all the propaganda
in media and social media that everybody
but themselves is in charge
you don't like the school take your kid
out you don't like America [__]
move go Paige hey Gary hi sing nice to
meet you such a pleasure thank you for
being here thank you I have a question
around succession planning oh you and
your brother you lead the The Firm I'm
sure you think about this you got kids
all of us have kids we have a lot of
Happy nepotism here so I'm just curious
how the 12 and A2 fit in with that well
number
three is a big one we just touched on it
like you know my kids you know I think
all of us who've garnered success
especially if we didn't start with
anything have feelings towards this I
think about accountability look look
I'll give you a really good answer to
this when all those really wealthy
people started saying things 10 years
ago that they were giving 99% sent to
charity right Gates and I was like
that's crazy cuz I come from immigrant
family where like everything's passed on
I promise you I don't think that's crazy
anymore you know what do I think about
succession plan I think it's about
parenting I'm thrilled to talk about it
in the macro I have no interest in
telling anyone here what to do that's
their business their money their
prerogative but what I will tell you is
you want your kids to be hungry don't
feed
them like you know like people I'm on
the board of charity water we build
wells in Africa one of the things that's
incredibly passionate to me as something
that I just when I got educated about it
I just couldn't understand as we you
want to talk about gratitude number
one
730 million people on Earth right now do
not have access to clean water within a
day water the [__] that is on your
table that really shook me you know you
want to talk about real like you know we
think about all this you know right
water so we it's amazing when I got
involved with Scott Harris you should
all look up Charity water it's pretty
profound if you want to learn a little
bit about it anyway it was a billion
people only 10 years ago I'm really
proud of the work I put a lot of time
and effort into it and I'm a well member
which means we pay our donations pay for
the staff it means if you give a dollar
it all goes to the work not the [__]
that we see with these nonprofits anyway
enough of that
commercial my friends hit me up all the
time hey Gary you're a well member on
charity water can I send my kid to
Africa with you for a week to be on the
ground I'm like you can and you should
but if you think your private school
private jet riding 17-year-old is going
to go to Africa for a week and somehow
profoundly change into another human
being you're at of your goddamn
mind my friends none of us can fake
environment you can't fake environment
what we can do is teach our kids that
it's not their money and they should be
kind to
people what we can do is stop giving
them
money that's your choices but as
succession planning I think a million
dollars one million dollar inherited is
an obnoxious amount of money and so I've
stopped thinking about that a long time
ago
because I think about all the kids that
are growing up right now that grew up
the way I am that would kill my kids in
any level of competition in merit-based
business and that doesn't bother me I
don't want my kids to be entrepreneurs I
don't want my kids to be even business
winners I want to be kind and I want
them to like what they do the way I like
what I do my favorite part about being
an entrepreneur is I love the game not
the things the game allows me to
buy last question
Ryan what if I answer it fast can I
sneak one more in or do you want to get
me the hell out of here yeah this this
is the last one how much time we got I'm
just having too much fun maybe five more
okay
good uh Ryan here Ryan a question to you
so I started consuming your your content
at the beginning of the pandemic you
gave a speech sort of like this but
talking about the power of branding yes
marketing which a common theme so
something you said a minute ago is if
you get one person in this room to take
away uh something that's that's worth
your time being here so to the 98% of
people I think that you said about
LinkedIn will under poost on LinkedIn so
what are some tactics you talk a lot
about tactics in your content so what
are some tactics to the 98% here or
maybe the one uh that would be good a
lot more LinkedIn since listening to
that and learned a ton over time what do
you you know so I'm not saying it since
you're their contemporary in that
learning over this time what's an
observation what's an aha what's a thing
you went into it not thinking was real
but you were inspired to go down the
path which I'm trying to do for everyone
give me one or two things that have
stood out I I would think authenticity
if if you are yourself and you're not
trying to be somebody different I think
that's huge let me let me jump on that
one friends as you think about what
you're going to post you could post
about loving God Golf and loving what
you don't need to post directly about
this job getting people in common
interests is a huge way to do business
you know this why' you join all the
country clubs and the PTA and all this
stuff so M step one mixing your content
it doesn't have to be literal
information about the product and
service if you love
Zelda you will be blown away how much
money you can make by talking about
Zelda especially if it's a repost and
you how somehow we clever to what they
post posted and you posted on top of it
and made some sort of reference to like
Mike Tyson's punch out that Snicker from
the person I can't believe you brought
up glass Joe from
1989 might be the reason they do
business with you it's profound how
humans actually work keep going um
authenticity also a repost of what
somebody's done is not necessarily
content well I would say a repost
correct a repost Without You adding your
two cents is less effective notice how
earlier I used the analogy of DJ I think
a lot of us know what happened in the
last 20 years with EDM and and DJs were
like you're like wait a minute like did
they even do anything and yet they're
super famous that's what you can do you
could
do you could take a very good post on
what you believe is well from someone
else not even in this ecosystem or from
the corporation you could repost it with
a quote and add a sentence to it now
you're a DJ you're like a vichi out here
100% I would say the last thing is um we
all make money on is Insurance don't
necessarily talk about insurance yeah I
think that's right I as I referenced
earli fishing all this stuff I think
it's a mix uh there was another book I
wrote called jab jab jab right hook and
it talked about the individual post can
be Jabs you're not setting up the reason
most people in Insurance when I analyze
it both on the brand or on the
individual level don't succeed is every
one of your posts is a sales pitch and
they smell it and they're not
interested when you start mixing it and
you start start talking about Zelda and
golf or this is a big one make pretend
that you retired from this and you've
now started an insurance media business
you're now the Bloomberg or CNBC of
insurance and you're not talking as a
human who's trying to sell something but
you're talking a level up about the
space or the opportunities or this new
tax law you're talking about
information that's
education that becomes a Gateway that's
a good framework to Think Through I say
one last last thing please is don't give
up I feel like two post yeah I mean that
goes back to seven tenacity like this is
what always blows me away people that
got in this room you put in the work and
then you go into this new Arena and
you're like four posts in you're like I
suck [__] that Gary
guy the first thousand posts I made
meant nothing so like I'd like to think
that this room understands what a good
day's work put putting in the work
learning really means and how that can
actually imp
the outcome and so yeah I mean look I I
really think the content thing is very
misunderstood like very people they they
have all sorts of feelings about social
media that it's bad that the kids I get
it
but I really hate making headline
reading opinions your business
strategy let me sneak one minut I'm the
worst I know one more somebody he told
me he's like S I got to get out here 355
got a roll anybody got a Qui question
here right you saw the board um yes you
saw the board here with all I did which
fired me up I wanted you know how crazy
I am Christina I saw the board I'm like
like literally my DNA I'm like I need to
get to the top of that [__] board
like like like I'm like should I retire
and join this company to get on the top
of the these boards [__] me up but go
ahead all right two
questions how do you get to the top of
that board using all 12 and a half by
knowing which two or three to use in
every circumstance both on the customers
you're trying to get and on the
employees that work for you second and
I'm just going to use myself as an
example because let's say we have
somebody on the board uh or a group of
people on the board what what have you
like someone in your company maybe
you've got a great salesman you know
he's top he's you know he's top of the
game and
he's there's some toxicity around yeah
uhuh
do you risk
that so it's interesting in my company
yes because everyone's an actual
employee of the
corporation this is a little bit of a
different framework right like this is
not this is not a corporation and you're
all employees you have your own [__] my
answer to that is a little bit different
my answer to if you look at that board
and you're like damn I want to get there
but I don't want to compromise or act
like that that goes to a thing that me
and my father thought about for 20 years
when I started working for my dad at 22
years years old I told him I will spend
zero minutes on our competition he
thought that was the craziest [__] he
ever heard he was obsessed with what
every liquor store in New Jersey did and
what they got did they get a better deal
on this vodka why didn't like he just
spent all his energy on everyone else I
said Dad the only people I'm going to
pay attention to is first star
employees second are customers and way
down here number 29 I'll have a sense of
what the competition's doing because you
never want to be delusional and
audacious but when I tell you very few
seconds will be spent on them because
what they do has no impact I promise you
if I started in this company tomorrow
had no contacts on that board within a
half decade I'd be the first person on
this board I promise you because nothing
and no one on that list is stopping you
from doing what you need to
do agreed thank you awesome let's give G
thank you thank
you